foreign
folks here we are we might be drunk
special guest uh Miss Pat
what we're just saying have we met I met
you years ago I don't know if you
remember it but we met on Last Comic
Standing
oh briefly
absolutely not I was gone early oh what
I think I made it one one episode yeah
how about you you run for a while I made
it to they picked they ate that's pretty
good that's good that's good TV time oh
it sucked I got eliminated on my
birthday what
damn harsh it was Keenan Roseanne and uh
Russell Peters Norm oh oh wow Norm was
really cool to me but uh Keenan I think
buried me and I was like I'm done I
didn't think uh Norm like me oh okay
well he's been known to be racist
he would say that out these days
you'd have never said that [__] if he
was alive no we would try to get him on
yeah although I think Roseanne was one
who took ambient oh that's true true
that was before Amber yet that was
before she was very nice she was I knew
her before yeah I love Roseanne I do too
yeah we call it ba before Ambien was she
nice to you yeah I did a show called the
world funniest mom and she was like the
host of it oh nice years ago and so um
and I opened for I opened in Vegas for
once a couple times so she's always nice
yeah she went Trump crazy and she
blocked me on Twitter no no way she
blocked you yeah I was like I thought it
was friend Roseanne wow yeah on Twitter
I feel like she's back on the scene now
I see her doing sets yes that you're out
you know let's see here pop up here and
there I bet if you saw her she'd be cool
with you face to face yeah okay I mean
you know people so we all get a little
crazy here and there sometime man here
here we all go a little mad sometimes
huh we all go a little mad sometimes
psycho yeah either wrong with that [__]
it's cream also it's what scream scream
also yeah oh yeah
that guy from the 90s that actor scream
scream I don't give any kids yeah he's
as good as it gets the hate crime is as
good as it gets yeah beats up Greg
kaneer yeah that's him remember him
well he do I think
oh he was just quoting him he literally
says that he goes Anthony Perkins psycho
yeah he quotes him
he said we all get a little mad
sometimes oh going on what you said can
we what are we drinking tonight uh it's
the day for us we're doing Amaretto
sours somebody must told you that's what
I do that's what you drink yeah we asked
do we asked Rosie
what kind do you usually do just like
sour mix and Disaronno or are you open
to a fresh one then yes look at you with
the lime's all lined up what a pro where
the hell y'all get this sexy ass box
I grew up in Atlanta just like you
really yeah
uh I'm from Norcross oh he's from one of
money
outside Hospital though oh Northside
Hospital they don't even take Medicaid
you gotta be assured to bring your ass
over the North Side open up your vagina
they will push that baby back in your
ass and send you down to Grady hospital
you're out boy that no I know a Side
Hospital you'll never hear me say I was
born at Grady hospital and Grady they
dropped the kids and give them ID and
tell them get a job the day they come
out the vagina
I don't remember the hospital I just
remember my mom kept the pamphlet
because my brother and I were on the
front of it like it was like what from
the late 80s day was on the pathway at
the hospital
wow you guys are lucky I was born in a
living room
really yeah I thought you were gonna say
I was born in a holler I thought he's
gonna see a trailer oh fish
hey Pam hello Pam what happened your
mama was loose and just let you go she
was on the toilet she forgot no she uh
an Elvis birth yeah I think she was just
uh you know procrastinating she was
procrastinated you just fell out like
that yeah you cut your coat I think my
dad oh well you know that you're proud
your parents probably playing this [__]
maybe they're a little hippie dippy yeah
cause you know white people believe in
having their babies underwater and you
know being born at the house and let the
other kids slap it to make it cry but I
was like I'm going to the [__]
hospital when they give you mayonnaise
and I can steal the napkins we ain't
gonna be pushing all babies out anyway
anywhere you know probably what are you
20 what 30 maybe 39 I'm old yeah yeah
yeah you getting up there yeah so your
mom probably was a hippie they smoked a
little weed they wanted to be free
exactly they probably got you after
birth in the freezer yeah the placenta
yeah yeah it was fun but no I mean no
drugs
who didn't do drugs my mom like no
epidural oh yeah she went Natty Natty
which is insane which is [__] crazy
crazy and when people say that I think
there's I mean personally I think
they're stupid because that [__] hurt
like nothing else yeah but some women
are able to take that paper I was like
let me tell you something give me enough
dope for me and debate you hear me both
of us need to be high yeah they need to
push yourself out of me give me I'm I
want all the drugs yeah give me stitches
I don't need yeah how many kids do you
have four oh wow wow
good for you you ain't got no kids no no
I'm barren
[__] you mean you bear I'm uh infertile
I shoot blanks how you know unlike Alec
Baldwin well I can I've just uh was that
an ALICE boss [__] joke somebody
gonna whoop your ass these undercover
jokes you keep yeah no he's catching
Strays and I see him in my local coffee
shop all the time Baldwin yeah and I I'm
nervous because I posted a lot of jokes
about him and I'm gonna espresso shot
all right all right yeah I want to say
hi but I couldn't pull the trigger I've
seen him one time uh at a I don't know
what side of town I was on he was at a
um like an Italian restaurant I went
with a producer one time and he was
sitting next to me with a whole bunch of
other celebrities and I guess they
wanted me I felt like they wanted me to
say oh Alice ball I was like I'm not
speaking if you're not speaking right
yeah you don't want to start that yeah I
didn't want to run up on him and [__]
the man was eating yeah noodles and [__]
I ain't gonna [__] with him but he was
sitting right next to me it was before
you know sure yeah he's cashing he
catches a lot of Strays on this podcast
but you shoot it's a lot of stress you
are nervous no I wasn't what you mean I
ain't been shot on no movie Set [__]
ain't nobody made a mistake and shot me
they was trying to shoot me all right
yeah he was playing with a piston yeah
that's how he got shot no that's how he
shot oh yeah yeah he's trouble is he
going to jail no it's up in the air I
don't think it was a manslaughter or
like involuntary manslaughter I think it
was a different news story every week
about it I don't think nothing gonna
happen too I I think it was an honest
mistake it was an accident yeah at least
that's what I hope yeah he's a nice guy
he looks exhausted you see he's got like
seven kids oh I've seen him again at the
hotel uh in Beverly Hills where they
shot pretty woman at oh yeah yeah she
got shot too I'm kidding no what
Beverly Hills Hotel oh I saw him there
coming out with his wife and a whole
bunch of babies on a nanny oh really a
whole bunch of Toddlers and small kids
and a Manny well his wife had so many
kids that she speaks like a Hispanic
person here she is I don't get it fake
accent George Santos
listen she was born in Boston
is that his wife yeah now she can do a
fake accent for you Beverly Hills
she was born in Boston
she has a fake act two white regular
American parents she puts on this fake
Spanish accent because she lived in
Madrid why but no one knows
no it's cultural appropriation she's
just pretending to be uh Hispanic yeah
yeah no one knows why she want somebody
to feel sorry for her
white women
what you gonna do next [__] be the
nanny
she's she's done half a dole is all
basically there you go she's gone like
halfway Rachel Dole Is All remember her
oh yeah the right to fool black people
because we really thought she was right
you black Rachel really worked
worked to get her skin to accept cocoa
butter so pull her up who's doing only
fans now
she signed up I like black women well
that ain't no [__] black
you don't give it to the fake black
woman
porn is getting so specific though now
it's like white women who act black yes
I want to be black we're the coolest
people in the [__] world
when you go all the way and use all the
Vaseline and you
you black she should get an Oscar well
that's impressive well she should have
did was open up a job and say I'm black
I [__] with a screen negro
and the words of Roseanne I didn't know
the [__] was black
but you know what I gotta tell you the
lady who she caught who she said that
too I saw her at The Breakfast Club
years ago and I was like that was a
pretty damn good joke Roseanne yeah it's
kind of funny tweet yeah pull her up
because she is kind of uh ambiguous
looking Who ah she's a politician I'm
using the correct words I don't think
she was a politician I think she was
like a senator or uh something he's on
it we call him Google [__] here we go
Oh I thought the [__] was black sorry
wait Valerie Garrett Valerie there you
go all right let's check out Valerie
Valerie Jarrett
we're gonna get Roseanne on here I love
that she says I thought the [__] in the
apology yeah yeah that's a good point
look she's kind of all over the road
here
look at that I mean Meghan markle's
blacker let me see the mega Marco is
definitely blacker oh yeah I mean that
is a little ambiguous
back in time she's look at that okay
okay yeah wow she's like a reverse
dolezal she's getting whiter
she's going the other way she's [__]
black she just light skinned it
yeah yeah
oh wow there you go it's kind of look
alike really they should do a podcast
together
after she run her career took her show
off TV I don't think so well that was
more Netflix I'd say but who knows that
was not Netflix Oh I thought it was a
Netflix thing Roseanne was ABC it was
ABC she highest number Oh I thought it
was something she was getting like 20
million views yeah she was like bringing
back TV
like it was you know she was she was
killing that [__] yeah and it was good
too was it yeah but what's crazy is they
still on without her I know it's kind of
hard they better not I better not say
the wrong thing they keep my [__] on how
many seasons are you in now this is
season three oh congratulations really
cool thank you and you've got an Emmy
nomination
first time for BT or BT plus that's the
first time a bet show has gotten that
yeah ever what
yeah that was pretty good wow we over
there trying to make a little bit of
noise they be trying to ignore them but
we'll be we'll be knocking on the door
hey [__] we over here too how do
you find out you're getting I mean uh
who tells you that well it just comes
out like on it comes out you found it on
like Twitter no no not Twitter it's a um
my co-producer uh found out it's some
somewhere they let it go before the
public knows like for writers and stuff
through the writers gear and is it how
did they find out
it's like
I guess Vietnam's denominated Jordan
knew it before it hit the internet
he was watching it as they was nominated
huh
I don't know where the [__] he from I
thought he found it on some Secret
website all right and he came in my
trailer Jumping Up and Dance and we got
nominated for him and I was like what
the [__] you talking about we're on bet
that [__] don't happen over here right
he's like no we got nominated for uh
Emmy for the first season and it turned
out to be true who do you lose to
we lost a tear last so we won that's
tough yeah that was a good show even
just to be uh but the director got
nominated but even just to be you know
on that platform and to be up against
the shows that we was up yeah I think
Elementary was in there Ted lasso was in
there uh murder what is it murder at the
elevator or some [__]
Steve Martin Show yeah that'd be a hard
show to write murders only in the
elevator we got to keep killing people
in this one spot this is tough but we
was up against some good people and it
was damn good yeah it was it was just
nice to be there it's just not really
strong yes I'm not a big alcoholic
person thank you sir these guys look
like they drink everything oh [__] he
got the fruit and everything yeah we did
Cheers Cheers to uh
nothing wrong with that and it was for
the it was for the pretty provocative
episode right
the nomination
it's displate time get your own artwork
printed on a metal poster that only
takes 20 seconds to install just pop
that magnetic sticker on the wall and
hang that poster no holes in your wall
and change it in seconds they have
officially licensed design from Fight
Club alien South Park and more if you
can think of it they can print it on a
metal poster click the link in our
description to see some of our favorites
and get get your ready to hang piece of
art that's 27 if you buy one or save 27
if you buy one or two and get 34 off
when you buy three or more discounts
will automatically be applied to your
cart when you click the link or use code
drunk when you visit display.com that's
display.com code drunk or click the link
below of the show notes
fitbot is a new app that creates an
exercise program around your goals
equipment and schedule it's the easiest
way to work out hey man we're all trying
to get fit oh yeah look we take horrible
cares of ourselves cares that's how
hungover I am I just cares instead of
care we take bad care of ourselves we're
trying to get fit we're trying to stay
in shape here so you know we don't feel
bad I don't know I feel terrible right
now fitbod varies your routine for you
to avoid over training way cheaper than
a personal trainer fitbot is easy to use
on both IOS and Android devices their
video tutorials make it easy to learn a
new routine you can get a full year
personalized workouts with fitbod for
less than the cost of one session with a
personalized trainer join fitbot today
and build a routine that grows with you
without slimming down your wallet 25 off
your subscription or try the app for
free when you sign up now at fitbod.me
drunk that's
fitbod.me slash drunk
the baby daddy about my baby daddy they
got nominated
[__] my baby daddy
take you home
yeah using you right
I really this is the perfect way to use
them I don't know I don't want to [__]
them I'm fine with this speak for
yourself
and maybe a few more there you go that
is damn good very good got Bodega cat in
it not not too much but a little Bodega
cat whiskey hunt you say you got what in
it
you want one yeah I want one
yeah they do so let's keep them going
better than what we had last night hell
yeah
Pammy that is that's gonna get us
absolutely here
does your dog want one does noodle want
one you got your dog here oh I thought
yeah she brings her everywhere oh no
you're a [__] dog okay boy that is
damn good sir you should do the
shirtless I heard that uh that Norman
Lear hit you up whoa
yeah I went to his 100th birthday party
what wow wow you know he just hit you up
because he's a fan well he saw the show
and um
um he heard about the show and they sent
him they sent him some episodes and he
called me whoa and I was [__] blown
away am I and my co-creator is more like
of a sitcom geek than I am
and he just called to say how much you
know he really liked the show you know a
lot of stuff we doing back in those days
he was trying to do what they would only
let him get so far right and then he
gave us a big shout out on the internet
and then he ended up inviting me to his
100th birthday party oh it was really
nice you know here normally here say hey
you got something here that's incredible
and it's the first thing I ever created
for TV and you get a call from Pimp
Daddy Norman Lear yes the TV King yes
and he's so Lucid at 100 it's amazing
he's like with it I mean I went to his
birthday party and the first thing I
said hi and the [__] are you still awake
exactly
I've been asleep three times waiting on
my time to get on stage it's it's I'm
tired as hell right yeah but he was
really nice he's really nice yeah what
is did he say have you asked him how is
he is that rude to be like how are you
still alive no I was just hoping he
stayed alive until his birthday party
you know because Betty White checked out
uh so I really wanted to go to his party
so I was so happy to know that my ticket
my plane ticket wasn't going to be
wasted right
thanks for not dying United's a real
[__] let me make it to the party let me
make it to the party he walked in like
it was a party like uh a bunch of people
that was on his show and a bunch of
people work with in the industry and
just like that well Jimmy Kimmel was
there I met Jimmy Kimmel that night love
camel and so we we have it was nice the
food suck ass really well you know
Hollywood people don't eat oh good point
they don't eat they don't swallow right
they don't want the real calories like
my ex
she didn't swallow but yeah
this is a part of this podcast are you
just over there running your mouth
I do that all the time like this is why
this is why it should have worked who
did somebody dump you no no I'm married
you married yeah sorry swallow the X the
X yeah so you didn't think this joke was
gonna be broken down this time
who the [__] is he talking to I just
thought he was talking to somebody on
the wall well I'm just making a joke
I enjoyed it it kind of scared me when
people just randomly running their
[__] mouth I'm really looking from
places where you know people run their
mouth like there's something wrong with
that's what I'm looking like you the
[__] okay I probably have some problems
because I need to know if I need to hit
you or get the [__] up
tell me what's going on I mean I'm you
ain't nobody invisible sucking your dick
is she no you have a whole conversation
by yourself no no I'm just joking around
didn't mean to scare you
a little bit you did you know you got
that little school shooter face
I never finished school but
you didn't finish school I'm joking I'm
finished
I went to Community College
no college for me oh yeah
who needs it I regret I wasted six years
you know my daughter was in uh uh she's
on her third she was on her third degree
I was like please drop out this [__]
yes it just all it does it puts you in
debt and you never gonna leave out the
house right so you haven't been out the
house you never had a job now what the
[__] you keep getting all these degrees
for sounds nice that sounds really nice
and so I told her I said come right on
my show with me so she
daughter's writing on your show yeah all
my kids work on the damn show beautiful
wow that's great yeah whatever the [__]
they cost what do they all do my son
worked in construction my one of my
daughter does makeup and then I have a a
daughter-in-law that works in another
department and then I have a uh my
daughter writes on the show one of my
friends and stuff like that is your
daughter really funny she she should be
a [__] comedian she's very funny well
she's kind of technically a comedian
she's a comedic writer right yeah but
she she could do stand up too she really
could she really could but she won't
she's kind of shy
but she she been writing on it now for
three seasons and we also developing
some other stuff we just sold another
show together wow where do you sell it
uh BT plus they have something over at
Netflix too oh my God I wish you were my
mom
[Laughter]
[Music]
my kids did the same [__] oh okay
wow a 40 year old with your 50 year old
a [__] mom how old is your daughter
by the way 36. are you kidding me wow no
that is that is yeah I had it when I was
14. so that's crazy wow yeah is that is
that cool do you like that you're so
close in age I'm not somebody [__] me oh
my God yeah
somebody [__] me and I can't break
well I'm sorry about that and don't be
sorry woman that bad oh okay all right
still you got a great relationship with
your daughter you work together you're
selling shows but not that daughter no
daughter is 24. I'm married to her daddy
that's the first daughter who does he
have my gay daughter
um gotcha okay I assume you don't speak
to the guy who [__] you at the when
you were 14. he didn't write me he
[__] me oh okay I had two kids by him
he's married oh okay oh wow yeah okay is
he right on the show
no he don't run he can't [__] read
no he don't ride on the [__] show
last time I talked to him he had like
three open heart surgery wow wow yeah
well so he I don't really talk to him he
always sent me a message through
Facebook he speak emojis
but it's cool you guys are still
you're cool I mean it's a it's not I
don't have a relationship but hey but
it's I've been married 31 years I have
nothing to say to him yeah and we we had
a we had a really crazy relationship
sure I was 12. he was 22 when I made it
wow wow that's uh wow wow so long it was
yards 12 is Young
yeah I mean anyone else hard
I'm joking I'm joking
but actually the wow was you're not
supposed to do that yes yes you're not
supposed to [__] a 12 year old how was
it that was the wow I was not on Epstein
Island
another joke I think the women on
Epstein's Island were older I think they
were I think they were older than me I
hope so yeah yeah not that much older
but older yeah I think 14 15. yeah so I
got a real question is it difficult
disciplining a kid that's like 14 years
younger than you because I'm 30 years
older than my seven-year-old and like I
can't control them
the [__] a seven-year-old talking back
oh see which is I mean it's black and
white people we just raise different
yeah Italians and Mexicans and blacks we
kind of all the same people white people
y'all just be like y'all read too many
[__] books to do [__] stop reading
the book and take the [__] life away
set your [__] ass down you know
this back in the day I'm 50. so back in
the days was not a such thing as ADHD
right you know my I had a special need
uncle and with my special need Uncle
actor my granddaddy whooped his ass whoa
he like see some and he was crippled he
said I told you don't piss at school
before or after the beating who you
would tell him I'm gonna whoop your ass
cause you pissed on that school bus
damn that's a double whammy how is Cecil
doing now he been dead
I feel like this is is this a cautionary
tale I don't know what the point of the
story
was special need and he got his ass beat
yeah when he act up that's not good he
used to like to call 9-1-1 because he
was fascinated with the police uniform
no he was scared police really started
whipping [__] asses right so they used
to wear bow ties in Atlanta and he would
love to choke the police out and he
choked the white woman out one time and
I'm not lying I think I seen the police
department falling out the air they
whooped my uncle ass when they fold my
[__] Uncle up because he was crippled
especially they followed his ass up like
an envelope and they drug his ass in
that Paddy Wagon he went to jail and he
went and when he got to jail they you
know they know he was special needs
right and um they let him go they ended
up letting him go my granddad beat his
ass because he used to love to die 9-1-1
and hang up and back in those days it
was no star 69 the police just came out
and when they got down he was anything
in uniform my if my if my granddaddy was
alive now and you could like he would
put a change around my uncle waist
because he loved people he loved to beat
the [__] out of people in uniform so
when he took him to the girl so he would
have a change around his way so when he
act up he will yank him back is this in
the show this is good stuff
I mean that's gold that's pretty funny
oh a flashback scene you just make it
look a little fizzy when you shoot it
yeah
oh but oh about uh my granite Easter uh
I'm quite sure I watched my space but my
grenade he my uncle was up he was he was
especially back in those days we could
say the [__] red but we can't see it
anymore sure he would have seizures so
my granddaddy thought it was only
because he couldn't bust nuts so he
would buy him [__] and once he bought
my uncle [__] he thought that would
calm down seizures and me and my sister
had to go in there and help my uncle get
ready with the prostitute because he was
crippled you know crippled people needs
going in like a kangaroo right so we
would go in there and pull his legs
apart so he could get some [__] and you
know I didn't mind helping my uncle get
[__] it's the excitement because you
know he was special need uh stop smiling
sticking dick in this [__] so I can go
play Pac-Man
that was the first Dick I ever seen and
it was so big it was so [__] big
there was times I whip guys I'd be like
a season dick wow it was so big what a
waste no it was not a waste yeah
he's not you don't get to migrate about
him my uncle be he's been there tearing
them [__] up with his knees knocking
wow well special needs dick is bigger
yeah what is that [__] dick is
bigger I think uh I grew up with a
special needs kid no Cecil and we didn't
buy him any [__] but uh he had a real
Honker really I mean it was like a
parking cone it was insane it went it
was orange it made a shape like it's
like a triangle it's so [__] white
your mama said a Honker I mean hunger is
a real piano leg by the way what is
Sally keeps looking up is he looking up
like a Honker I see you googling
[__] dick and you will see some real
tree trees how quickly is this episode
gonna get demonetized
why aren't we making money off the
[__] dick episode I'm telling you we
lost all our sponsors [__] strength is
no joke yeah I mean that's the truth
cause my uncle he used to like to eat
rice do you want to eat grits if we from
the south you know we love Greece oh
yeah he would only eat out of a pot with
the handle burnt on the end whoa so my
granddad ended up shooting his neighbor
like eight times because she called him
a big black [__] or some a [__] or
some [__] I don't know I'm just telling
y'all these are stories so don't come
after me for those words right right
other people so my granddaddy pulled out
two pistols and they were 38 he shot him
like but with both pistols and so he
ended up in jail and my mom had to keep
on because he said and we [__] around
and left his pot somewhere one day he
wouldn't eat and everyone said she take
the goddamn plate and he said I want to
play how about goddamn pop my mama slap
see some side of the head with all that
Rice went down
you know what he and I remember when he
passed away and I had never seen a uh
person who was crippled um so I was like
how y'all gonna put him in the casket
and he was like we're gonna break his
dick was that big no it was an open
casket
no because you know his leg when he legs
would be in the air when he was sleeping
so he's been act like a brick but he
broke his leg he was laying straight and
he was actually a pretty tall man after
he died
wow damn you go there's your parenting
tips you good beat your kids yeah big
dick shoot your neighbor
uncle's [__] right now he shot him and
they both I'm assuming died from this no
she didn't die she took off you shot him
eight times and they didn't die she
didn't die it was a woman he got like 10
years for shooting her wow I was sitting
on the porch with him that day he shot a
finger off
it's like a Tarantino movie
this is wild I was holding his leg and
he said now [__] I put all that hot leg
in hot leading he told my Aunt around
she's like why you shoot him daddy he
was like [__] up go back there and put
that moonshine out so they'll lock me
here you going to jail you don't shout
the [__] out there later and she was
just laying in the grass please I had to
be about eight years old wow why are you
shooting that [__] her that's what he
was saying [__] off damn and they came
and locked him up he had both his guns
he had laid them down police pulled up
he said I shot the [__] damn holy moly
[__] [__] her is also what he said to
Cecil apparently yeah yeah wow what a
story and that was crazy that was a
Tuesday
oh it was during the week
yeah how do you make the weekend even
come close I know right when you get
cease the hooker
Cecil's a great name
that really is ain't nobody named Cecil
no [__] that lion yeah remember the
Lion's diesel he was also shot
also had a huge [__]
[__] too I don't know R.I.P Cecil you'll
be missed damn how long ago did Cecil
pass oh probably 20 years ago he's been
gone a long time that's a crazy story
that you helped Cecil have sex oh all
the time me my sister and my granddad
would give us 50 Cent to go play Pac-Man
all right once he gets started cause
once he stuck the dick in he he was good
punch I'm the same way he just he didn't
have he didn't know how to hold his
penis and just get it in I guess and I
guess what I mean me my sister pulling
his leg we gave him aim right man that's
a close-knit family
damn you gotta write this into your show
that's a little no I'm not going bro
I don't think they'll let me get away
with that one BT plus it's right at
school I write a bunch of crazy [__] in
there but I did it on a special so I
don't know yeah but you could I mean
flashback flashback but I I don't even
know it I don't where would I get the
actor from
hey you'd have to get a special needs
person now because they get mad if you
uh if you imitate them yeah yeah I don't
blame them they was taking money out of
their pocket get your ass out that
wheelchair and let me who be in the
wheelchair for real being there there
you go I don't want you playing a big
fat black woman that's not fair to me
you gotta get a real prostitute too for
that oh yeah yeah did uh busting the nut
cure his seizures no I don't know what
my granddad came with this stupid [__]
Caesar still had seizures all the
[__] time he I mean he would have
seizures and we would put spoons in his
mouth and [__] oh damn and um and it was
we we was trained as kid he ever just
get a spoon and we couldn't use the good
spoon right you can use this plastic
either because he could swallow it so we
just get a tablespoon and stick it in
his mouth and let him chew and spin and
he lay there and then he always we
always had a good cold Pepsi waiting for
him when he woke up nice he like Pepsi
all right that was a good time it's
prostitute we're gonna get her on the
puck
yeah I guess that doesn't cure diseases
but I think we could definitely treat
more illnesses that way Michael just
bang hookers yeah exactly kids don't get
to do that those are great I never went
to Disneyland what would you rather be
Mickey Mouse or bang a [__] exactly you
know what people don't realize that
special need people need sex too oh
they're horny yes they're backed up they
need [__] sex too of course but we
just sat here and treat them like they
don't want to bust a nut my granddaddy
new season won the Boston every Friday
and Saturday he had him or and he would
he would give him [__] he would like
they would get a half a pint of gin
because that's what my Grandad sold he's
so moonshine and he so he saw corn
looking and he sold gin and single
cigarettes wow so if you go back and
[__] Cesar you get a half a paint nice
damn that's worth it it was like maybe
two dollars well the girl got a full
plate
see so damn that is crazy that's a crazy
story it's so visual too and the fact
that you helped with the pull in the leg
all that [__] me and my sister would
pull his leg wow I saw my brother naked
I was running for the hills let alone my
special needs Uncle and he's so he said
like he's always big for nickels and he
loved he's like hey girl give me two
[__] two [__] make a dime but he
didn't like dimes so he would have a
pocket full of chains so he always had
on two belts because all he did was ask
everybody who went in the bootleg house
for nickels wow so I when we had to get
those pants off him you let that belt go
it sounded like a [__]
jackpot
take him to a coin star huh it was no
coin stars back then oh yeah I think
they're going away again
strip clubs take venmo
true story
hey you probably think you spend around
80 a month on subscriptions when the
actual toner's closer to 200 most
Americans do you could be wasting
hundreds of dollars each month on
subscriptions you don't even know about
that's why we love rocket money formerly
known as true bill rocket money shows
all your subscriptions in one place even
the ones you didn't know you were paying
for and cancels whatever ones you don't
want you may even find out you've been
double charged for a subscription it
happens to cancel a subscription just
press cancel and Rocket money takes care
of the rest easy
get rid of useless subscriptions with
rocket money now go to rocketmoney.com
drunk seriously it could save you
hundreds per year that's rocketmoney.com
drunk cancel your unnecessary
subscriptions right now at
rocketmoney.com drunk
hey folks word we might be drunk is
brought to you by tushy hello
Taco Tuesday was a great time but let's
be honest now things are rough down
there thank God for hello tushy the
bidet that keeps things clean no matter
what junk you've put in your body you
got to use tushy to wipe that b-hole
clean especially now with the uh the uh
what's it called fornicating in the you
know the old uh eat in the back door if
you know what I mean that's very popular
these days and you don't want to have a
nice snail Trail back there and you
definitely don't have a couple of shreds
of TP and a peanut and a piece of corn
so get yourself some tushy folks and
clean that back porch because people
want to go in there yeah so
the hello tissue bidet cleans two times
better than wiping and prevents poop
particles from spreading to your hands
and everything you touch it attaches to
your existing toilet requiring no
electricity or additional plumbing and
it cuts toilet paper usage by 80 percent
Save the Planet you Kooks
if you do the math tushy pays for itself
in just a few months every hello tushy
bidet attachment comes with a 60-day
risk-free guarantee and a 12-month
warranty with over a hundred thousand
five star reviews see why millions of
people already love hello tushy and be
part of taking care of business the
cleaner way go to hellotushy.com forward
slash drunk and use promo code drunk to
get 10 off plus free shipping on your
bid day order on your first one ten
percent off that's hellotushy.com
drunk for 10 off get on it folks
how do you pay the guy who's been to a
strip club recently I went last weekend
where'd you go uh Rochester what yeah
why there's nothing else to do yeah but
that's not where you want to go to the
strip club well that's why we went we're
like let's go see some down and dirty
how is the talent there not great what
was you at Rochester I forgot the name
of it using Rochester doing a gig yeah
New York yeah oh
there's a couple Rochester's around this
great nation isn't it there's one in
Minnesota as well yeah this is Rochester
um yeah I would never go to a strip club
in Rochester it was still a lot of
Cecil's walking around why because
the women will see something oh yeah big
dicks
damn yeah we popped in it was it was
weird you and Murphy no I was with the
Andrew Young Blood he was open he's from
there and we popped in we popped out
damn yeah
that sounds rough but I'll tell you go
to like one of these small towns you go
to the strip clubs I got two tequila
sodas it was like four bucks or
something really yeah because they want
you to buy the hose not the souls I
guess so yeah but in Vegas strip club in
Vegas they're like you know you get two
and then they're like buy me one and buy
my friend one you're like all right
they're like that'll be 200 you're like
what exactly I haven't gotten the dance
yet I know it's crazy 200 for somebody
no not really but it's crazy expensive
no Vegas is expensive oh yeah strip
clubs in Vegas are crazy and New York
too once a strip club when you married
well that's why you know you look don't
touch
right I like how she's passing judgment
after she helped her uncle get I was a
kid you need to shut your damn mouth wow
I'm with her shut the [__] up
what the hell
you should have me to be your Nanny yeah
you should you should discipline that
kid she'll kick your ass too he's
running ramps he's the [__] he's got a
ball girl
do we really talk back yeah what does he
say to you dude he's like uh no I won't
do that or stop it he'll stop it wow
people learned it from me yeah but
that's when you're trying to touch him
inappropriately oh my God okay
you you said he'll tell you to stop it
and did you stop it
no the thing I tried to talk to him like
you can't talk like that like I'm trying
to reason no give him a taste of the
back of the hand
oh geez yeah Ray Rice him yeah it's
tough dude cut him who gives a [__] how
to cut him he's already circumcised you
married yeah and what did she do he run
over her too uh
yeah yeah
uh did you see that special that um that
um uh thing on Netflix whatever those
people down in uh the murdochs yeah
that's what she's about to become we're
not rich you know you're about to be the
pole murder
you're about to be the murder that's
what you raise is there another way to
do it other than hitting them is there
some other solution yeah you got you got
to figure out that's a good one uh you
gotta figure out a way that you get the
baby y'all have letting this seven year
old take control of the situation you
gotta Jack his ass up to let him know
that you're [__] serious because you
lost control when a child can tell their
parents no
no no you don't lost control yeah I got
a 14 a 10 11. ain't no [__]
body in my house telling me no I will
slap your [__] eyes and your
eardrums there you go and get a metal
chain if you go to the grocery store and
yank that kid around I love your
callbacks yeah thank you for catching
that yeah you you losing control yeah I
mean you can get it back now as the
child is seven yeah all this time out
this is no respect yeah
this guy's got no respect at all now
what about if your woman's out of
control can I hit her
I'm joking again
try it and see what you uh end up at I
don't know she's already in a wheelchair
so that helps in a wheelchair yeah yeah
but he pays for her prostitutes too so
that's right uh I pushed her down some
stairs
white men do not put their wives in
wheelchair you just kill them true good
point Murdock yeah yeah shot his wife in
the face you know didn't he get busted
from the Snapchat or the video son when
he shot his son yeah the dog there's no
the sound was on Snapchat when he said
when he shot him yeah what is that
amazing yeah that's how you really got
caught he didn't know his son was on the
internet wow
something good came out of that app yeah
that app sticks yeah no it's amazing he
uh
he almost got away with it but yeah
still in the house key but they killed
the housekeeper hold on the dogs killed
the house
they killed a housekeeper the other son
killed supposedly killed a gay lover I
know yeah so either either that son is
gay or he's well yeah you never know his
name is Buster come on and who wasn't
they killed they had like five or six
bodies on their hands oh yeah boating
accident oh killed the girl on the ball
she was cute and and they got and they
got away with it yep yeah damn yeah they
really they really ran [__] in that town
oh yeah everyone for 30 for for years
for years Snapchat did anyone like it
but yeah they ran her reactions are as
fun as the joke right now this is I'm
quite sure they got a bunch of lights
after you heard boom boom like what the
[__] hey they get down over there yeah
you know what I did think watching that
though when they when they showed the
boyfriend run off the boat and he was
shirtless I was like Stu's got a good
body that's true he was hungry okay
works out a lot clearly he was like I'm
getting older I was like look at this
young buck right here oh yeah that
family should have been stopped a long
time ago yeah yeah that family but you
know even in those small towns you know
what even if he hadn't killed his wife
and son that boy by now would have been
so far out of hand because it had
covered up so much [__] yeah he I
mean he is the epitome of of all what is
it called White what oh boy Network
privilege Network White Privilege Yeah
Yeah well yeah it was one of those
things watching the dock that even
though they're wealthy it's like
watching succession you know even though
they're super wealthy or like this
doesn't look fun this doesn't look like
you're having a good life miserable
every picture they looked [__]
miserable they're drinking their sorrows
away oh yeah in the family when you see
how much they were drinking if you was
in North Carolina
I think it was South Carolina South
Carolina whatever any Carolinas yeah I
mean with 100 acres and all the money
and nobody still likes you did you not
see Buster I mean they wasn't the best
looking his the friends was way better
looking kids yeah he looked like Chucky
for [__] sake but he was still pulling
ass well they're the rich kids the power
yeah if he had a lot of money he could
ask well he got ass yeah he's got a wife
and a hot kid
look at that red ginger [__] yeah Jesus
he's good yeah he's gonna have to tell
the language he's gonna have a tough
life now I mean what he's lost everybody
in his family he got out of money uh
he'll be doing stand-up comments he was
just in Vegas really Neighbors in Vegas
doing uh doing the trial him and
Rittenhouse are doing a podcast
[Laughter]
the dad looks like Gary Busey too look
at that and he shaved his head that's
never a good sign bad luck no the daddy
lost all that [__] way too that's a
scary huh you know he looked like Woody
uh look a white man can't jump Harrelson
yeah he looked like Woody Harrison oh
come on what is better looking than that
guy Murdock Woody Harrison now
Woody looks I'm going what do you look
better look like Woody Harrison Ah
that's not bad actually damn the charm
goes a long way yeah he ain't Killed
Nobody this guy's not pulling Rosie
Perez and white man can't jump oh she
was hot huh well that dude that ain't
pulling Rosen Perez and white man can't
jump yeah that's when he was young right
yeah true really oil
Rosie Perez looks pretty good these days
still still holding up still holding
Puerto Rican don't Puerto Rican got
there what we got this [__] don't you
know it don't fade too quick you do not
look 50. that's crazy that you're 50.
well when you don't when you don't do
drugs and cigarettes and alcohol and
that much you know all skin hold up
pretty good there you go but I'm 50.
Chris Rock has got to be 58 he looks
amazing yeah he looks good incredible
it's nothing like black skin with money
yeah it's a whole nother different level
how about like Gabrielle Union she looks
ridiculous have you ever seen her
ridiculous good yeah hell yeah yeah she
looks good she do
Nia Long too what Nia Long's at the end
of that yeah Special she looks the same
as when she was in Friday so she's
beautiful yeah she also got [__] over
by that old Celtics coach he was like
[__] in-house that coach her
husband's just [__] he was trying to
keep it on he was trying to keep it
in-house and they let it go well you
can't you can't be [__] people's
wives in the house is that what she was
married uh other people he was people he
was [__] were married I believe I
think that's why he got let go
[__] one person no I think there were
multiple people yeah I think it was a
good morning America situation where he
was [__] a lot oh yeah you cannot
what was his name throwing all that dick
around Good Morning America
oh
Matt Lauer oh Matt Lauer he's a cute guy
in America the the interracy
yeah yeah and they was trying to hate on
him yeah no he was slicking some good
old D to that uh blonde lady it was more
than that blunt lady uh oh well he
[__] everybody on that show I mean if
you [__] yeah you got those nice
eyes oh yeah
he fought quite a few of them and they
together now right here to here he's
happy he's getting that guy's got no
jizz left that's a happy guy he's got an
empty sack for sure oh yeah
well you know he's chasing a lot are
y'all saying the man nuts empty oh yeah
yeah
the man is old as [__] I'm quite sure
they only had full field anyway that's
true this is like Freud does the ball
sack have four or is it it's an optimist
he shouldn't prune juice well I'm quite
sure he happy he's shooting prune juice
he should be done with having kids so
mommy dust pops out of his [__] when he
comes he's an older fella oh no he's
just older
some of this [__] going on my head
yeah he's uh I did their show once they
couldn't have been nicer they were great
oh yeah you were in the way
did you swing uh I would have if they
asked me oh really no but she was I
think she's pretty hot you never did a
threesome no I did have the guy walk in
on me once never had the threesome but
you jump on you no I'm not doing that
kind of shoes no it's not my thing
you've done a threesome yeah cup
[Laughter]
what is he doing now
chilling in the Hamptons I don't know
what he's doing he's getting fired yeah
I know he got fired for [__] sucking
his dick for positions but yeah
supposedly allegedly allegedly Katie
Couric was pretty damn hot
yeah she had a moment she's hot
what do you do when y'all well because
you what's your nationality white
Italian and French white my nationality
of asking
um like Eastern European Ashkenazi Jew
so you so pretty much white people right
yeah
so what do you do when you're women's
like you know because as
African-American women you know most
white women start about 35 and they
started to fade for them oh yeah
especially the Irish oh
a couple of pumpkins
but what are you asking
so be like cease
so how did that make you feel I mean do
you stick with them when they start to
wrinkle dude bother you I mean I'm
single but I I I well that's why you see
Leo with a couple of 11 year olds you
know because he's trying to get in early
who the [__] is Leo No 19 but that's 19.
but that's pretty awesome yeah
pull it up does it bother you does it
bother me that he did when the Angels
like that when women age yeah no it's
part of it's a bummer to deal with it
though yeah you know [__] did you get
him from
but you love them so you stick with them
and then now they go there's all kinds
of well it doesn't it doesn't bother me
because I'm not I don't think I've been
in a relationship crack of lotion oh
yeah Botox the lotion Pam you're on half
that [__] you know it's uh they got the
shots and the the Peels and the
surgeries
what's that you know what pam pam is Pam
doesn't get to disclose my relationships
this is pretty rude seriously my
publicist trying to [__] suffering me
here yeah
yeah I'm taking shots
yeah she talks a lot she never stops
talking it's crazy you want to come on
here or what
she's really good at what she do but
we're so best in the business and I
really enjoy her as a person I do but I
hang up on her all the time I know I'm
always like enough Jesus yeah oh my she
loves to talk
I don't say that to her because that
could get me in a lot of trouble at some
point but she can't suck dick she's
still talking
you can't get the dick in there but
you as stupid as [__]
you don't know the [__] you talking
about because I know people who suck
dick while they talking wow that's a
small dick
I can barely talk with a toothpick and
let alone a penis you got dicks you suck
dick no I'm just saying if I you get it
no I don't I tried to suck my own once
and I I gotta Lick in yeah it's good to
get a lick in yeah I gotta lick serious
I tried
every guy tries see no I've never tried
to eat my [__] well that's well that's
much harder to get there's no length
yeah unless you got crazy labia yeah
what his name is
oh I call them lips oh okay lips yeah no
you gotta have you'd have to have a
really meaty situation down there to
reach the tongue it's just not gonna
happen or a huge [__] I have no who
wants to eat they [__] I've seen my
drawers I don't want to eat them laughs
yeah all right I think eating [__] is
great I'm gonna go I'm a fan I don't
care who I offend here I think eating
the lady's vagina is great yeah I don't
care how many female listeners I piss
off I don't care until you've seen the
under what we hid show me the underwear
the hidden underwear is that like legend
of the Hidden Temple
I put on goggles when I do it
do you yeah oh yeah that's how much
squirting happens yeah big squirter the
wife that's crazy
yeah the wheelchair you can't feel
anything but it's [__]
I put a broomstick in the wheels really
yeah she can't get away I'm she went
flying yeah yeah what is that cartoon
character with the yellow one with the
big glasses
uh yellow with the big green yellow they
look like little Dilbert oh the minions
the menus that's what you look like
eating [__] exactly
with her glasses on yeah that's me and I
get a Miner's hat with the light on it
man they are cute little things those
minions what are you doing fixing a
wheelchair why are you eating her yeah
I'm screwing in the hubcaps yeah big big
fan of the clam dive
the clam died you know eating the gas
no I don't know you know join the ham
wallet
the hatchet wound the honey pot the [__]
yeah come on what did you say he can do
five more
uh uh the Love Hole the vajayjay they
are with JJ the uh the Cooter the
coochieve the beaver
[Applause]
the cool like the weirdest episode of
Family Feud ever
fast money I'm from Louisiana we said
cooter
is that the name when you're sleeping
with your cousin
I had a second cousin who was pretty hot
would you second cousin really [__] I
tried
you ain't got no goddamn sense you buy
crazy as a damn empty wallet
yeah that's a good one all right that's
great do you have any pet peeves Miss
Pat
ah what is my pet peeves uh I don't like
my feet to be cold oh that's a big one I
get bad circulation too I sleep in socks
all the time really yeah not me I don't
like my feet to be called I don't really
want them by touching my feet
interesting yeah what about sucking the
toes ain't nobody never suck my [__]
toes okay all right I got dog feet
really yeah my mama said when she was
pregnant with me she had a little dog
that liked her and I came out with his
feet so I don't have no toenails what
they're very small they're like little
dots prove it
[Laughter]
what about dirty feet that's a problem
too you ever have dirty feet and you go
to bed you gotta wash them just gotta
wash them yeah I get in bed with dirty
feet
gonna get the the gonna get the sheets
ruined
oh you gotta watch the [__] anyway did
you take a bath every night when you go
to bed no I don't either I think that's
such a waste of water I agree how often
do you clean the sheets at home do you
think about once a week that's way
better way that's women of women are
better that's better than guys are
especially with those dirty ass feet
those dog feet my [__] feet
ain't dirty oh you something [__] I
said I got dogs I ain't told you nobody
was [__] dirty your [__] feet
dirty that's true
I got toenails at least
I have a peeve please you ever have that
friend who you who calls you but they
only have like a three minute window
where they call you but and then you
miss the call and you call back and they
can't talk again for like a week
[Music]
in jail
[Laughter]
dog feet in the house that was good [__]
he's so [__] silly it's a good one
though the guy who can't the call window
guy the call Window yeah that's no good
then you gotta wait a week and what if
it's important
it's never important but it's just
annoying that they're like they're like
I got three minutes now and then I have
to be around people for another week
right my I gotta peeve how about this
one the guy who's grilling you while
you're eating no pun intended but he's
like I'm eating a burger and he's like
so when what time is this when is that
I'm like oh I'm waiting on a tomato
hanging out of your mouth I'm like let
me finish eating it's like Alec Baldwin
you let him eat at the restaurant you
mentioned that earlier but I'm just
don't don't quiz me while I'm eating let
me get the food down and then we'll talk
no I know you the rapid fire it's the
question that bothers you it's the
uzi-like intensity yeah wow my mouth is
full so then I gotta see you see that's
your [__] problem you don't know how
to multitask you need to learn how to
swallow and speak well you know talk
with the food in your mouth anybody can
do that I'm trying to eat [__] here
what you say you were eating a bourbon
oh well that's what I call somebody
[__] alive
sure I hope you look like you licked
them Pocket [__] from Amazon
well I practice on those but yeah no but
the the burger I'll leave you added it
from Amazon the ultimate in so not only
is it a pocket [__] you needed it in
one or two business days what a slam
I have problems
[Laughter]
y'all still drinking the first one oh
you got a point there you gotta put on
it putting them back sister hang tight
this ain't what you usually drink is it
no I'm not I'm not a big sweet I'm not I
don't like sweet cocktails but this
tastes very good actually that's a
killer good job sour I'm more of a just
a whiskey guy if I do a cocktail more of
a Manhattan maybe or like a you know
don't know what it is just whiskey
vermouth bitters well but it's a good
[__] right I mean try to Beef It Up
with the bodega cat a little bit it's
got egg white in it too that's what the
smoothness is you do egg white too you
didn't do it like crustacean
that's how they do it at Chris station
in La oh we're gonna put the egg white
in it is that a cool spot yeah it's very
cool spot very expensive very good you
like do you like going to LA or no I
don't like it like I don't like New York
either whoa you live in Atlanta
neither usually you gotta pick one I
don't like neither this place is so
dirty that's true this is a dirty and um
the people walking right here act like
they don't even see the [__] rats the
rats are on their way to work I [__]
cannot stand this dirty and then they
don't have normal crazy people they have
crazy people like the lady who was doing
my makeup she said she was coming to do
my makeup and do walk them say I'm a sex
Defender so I'm about to touch you what
kind of [__] is that she said well I
have a knife he said never mind
kind of [__] is this damn so the
people here just like I can't then I've
never seen people get in arguments with
cars they don't care how they hit you
they walk out in the road it's just too
many people in this [__] it is a
lot of people dude I don't know if you
guys walked in when I walked in but when
I was coming up this block there was an
ambulance that was stuck yes did you
guys see that it just wouldn't move and
this is classic New York [__] I'm on a
phone call and like oh come on all right
literally maybe a person dying in there
and I'm like
but it wouldn't move and it was I [__]
you're not like seven minutes on one
block wow you're through an ambulance is
[__] bad but that's New York it's
that congested shouldn't have gone up a
busy Block in Times Square right
true yeah they literally whoever they
was picking up should have told them to
meet him at the other the end of the
street so he wouldn't block the [__]
whole street right so so where where do
you live I live in Atlanta oh you're
still there okay I was in Indiana for 15
years I just moved back last year that's
an upgrade I think yeah yeah I didn't
like Indiana at all I like Atlanta and I
love it and La is just too fake
everybody vegan everybody want to take
you out of dinner they chew and then
they go to the bathroom and spit the
food out right
um they're just too [__] fake I agree
they're a bunch of there's a land of
Google lies
so I don't like your lane and it costs
too [__] much yeah the traffic and
the smog and the homeless you can keep
going
homeless you know like in Atlanta the
homeless
late they just be like hanging out in
the street like they had the Marriott
you like excuse me sir he's like [__]
you [__] it's my bedtime
you trying to palette Park as a whole
human being right in that parking spot
because that's where they're gonna sleep
tonight I'm like what the [__] is wrong
with it how do you get control of this
homeless problem I don't know what to do
yeah well the drugs have made it so much
worse no it's the weather is so good
it's easy to sleep outside when it's
always 80 degrees Yeah if I was homeless
here I would just start walking just
give it until the last week this winter
hasn't been that bad here I got it
kicked up it kicked up the wind the wind
the snow it's snowed yesterday yeah
there was no snow that was this white
[__] falling out there that was cocaine
[Laughter]
um
yeah so I like the South I really like
the South Atlanta yeah yeah I'll be
there soon I like I like going where are
you coming to Tabernacle okay should be
fun I've done I've done the clubs for
years they're uh Laughing Skull and is
that still there punchline yeah back at
the diner yep see the jello while you're
doing your stand up oh that's fun
classic no I played that room for years
uh what do you think about Buckhead
why you had to say it like that well I'm
doing a gig there I want to get your
take bookies is really nice what are you
doing it at Buckhead Theater really
[__] nice oh really yeah all right I
saw Bill say Regis there it's not what
it used to be used to be party central
oh really yeah it's like real cleaned up
and yeah
well I'm in Atlanta in a long time I
moved here from Salt Lake City but I
grew up in Atlanta until I was like I
moved when I was 15.
oh two gay
in Salt Lake yeah in Atlanta that is
pretty good is it now oh yeah no I'm not
what what's wrong with it I really
thought you were gay no ah we'll fire
this guy no
everyone's gay for the right price Mark
you got that right what's in it for me
I'll give you a little Buck Head
Mark actually pays him a dollar he's
like his actual Buckhead
this thing yeah Buckhead is really nice
you're gonna like that theater it's
beautiful all right thank you I'm
excited what's your favorite barbecue
spot in Atlanta uh oh I just got back
last year I don't know I haven't had any
[__] barbecue how about just like
good food in Atlanta
I go to this place called uh where we go
breakfast is Barney's it's right over
there by Grady Hospital remember Grady
Hospital well they don't genture five
dollars that [__] they don't ran my
people out and the good old white people
don't came in there to plant flowers so
they thought my people couldn't plant
flowers
so you know they it's it's it don't even
look the same like when I grew up so
it's really nice restaurant popping up
every [__] wear the night scenerys
because it's something to do that's
every damn night right
all right let's do it yeah I go to
Barney's
so if you go call me and then I get you
in because it's hard to get it oh really
the line is down the [__] Street all
right really I'm excited I can throw
your neighbor
don't walk it in say my name oh okay I
mean I tell them you coming I appreciate
it yeah don't walk in that same as pay
you probably get your ass
she's a little hooker is gonna hit me I
don't know if it's still there you gotta
go check out Fat Matt's you remember
that place it was called Fat Matt's ribs
is it still there is it she said still
there yeah I think the first the first
time I came to New York this is like
five six years ago well it's not the
first time but I remember I went to go
see uh Aladdin on Broadway and the
lights came up at uh the intermission
and sitting like two seats over from me
was Andre Benjamin and he was wearing he
was wearing a fat mats barbecue t-shirt
wow
yeah the most dressed down like no
dangerous now yeah like but compared to
the you know the green suit and the
split you know like the law yeah he was
just just in the barbecue t-shirt and
said like I was the only person who
recognized them too underrated handsome
guy being kind of an underrated actor
he's actually a pretty good great actor
I mean obviously Outcast is amazing but
look at that he's a hunk he just I think
he just said hey I made my money I don't
have time for the [__] I want to
walk away wow is he done with Showbiz
you think I don't know
um we hoping one day for another album I
know Outcast was killer they got back
together for Coachella a couple years
ago Big Boy stole he's always around I
ran into him uh at the airport not long
ago oh yeah you say what's up yeah he
did I didn't recognize him uh my
assistant recognized him
um he had a grown a beard and mustache
and I I didn't recognize him yeah when
you're on the road do you do the road
pretty hard yeah what do you have any
things you do like you're like you got
to go to a good restaurant is there like
a routine you have no not really I don't
get out into the city I go to my [__]
hotel go to sleep perform and go back to
sleep okay because I do a morning show
in Atlanta and then uh you know I'm
always working on something trying to
develop or whatever during the week and
I'm building a house so I don't have
time for anything yeah it's a big house
I heard
it is oh that's exciting I heard from
Pam yeah I uh I decided to be my own
general contractor and I built the 17
000 square foot house wow that's huge
yeah no wonder you like Atlanta you're
living good yeah you could too if you
come on in there with me I'll jump down
you leaving New York for Atlanta wow if
I can check up with old Patty
I'm down I missed the South and I'll
stay your ass up here cause you're not
shaking up with no old Patty nobody made
it like that I just mean
[Laughter]
I mean
he's digging himself a bigger hole in
here I'm not saying you're over there
obviously
I [__] prostitutes before I'm not a
[__]
dabbled with the ladies so I'm just
trying to relate
you're not doing a good job all right
all right well this is a horrible speed
date
but
love Atlanta hot Atlanta they come I do
like Atlanta I'm excited to go I'm
excited to be there again great comedy
Town underrated audiences yeah great
crowds how big is the theater y'all
doing I don't know mine's not that big I
think mine's like 900 900. it's pretty
big I think I don't know yeah
Tabernacles definitely big yeah I'm only
doing a show though it'll be fun I'm
pumped I think Bill Byrd did the did the
black and white special there oh wow
yeah Buckhead Theater holds 1800. holy
[__] let's go you doing 1800 I'm excited
you'd [__] do it easily what are you
talking about I didn't know it was 18.
yeah you could stop it oh boy if I could
do it you could do it all right well
pull out my old Fat Matt's shirt
well what's what's a tabernacle pull
that puppy up
Atlanta It's both of them really nice Oh
I thought you said Tabernacle was 1800.
okay I think he did his [__] is 1800. no
I think mine is several rooms inside of
it oh okay maybe I'm doing the small one
I'm sorry it says 2600 but that can't be
true I think it's 18. wow this is 2600
it's pretty big that might be for music
though with like I think I think for
stand-up it's it's 18. 1911. Isn't that
cool that's the cool thing about
theaters is they're like Houdini play
yeah it's like the most random I'm just
I just started uh I started in September
I have a uh my first theater to a call
young girl done made it yeah and I'm
moving into theater but I really like
clubs clubs are fun you need both I
think
yeah clubs clubs to build and the
theaters to hone you know right is that
what it is I think I mean what do I know
I mean it's it's I agree I think it's
good to
theaters are cool it's cool to do them
but I think I mean I'm looking forward
to it I'm excited about moving into
theaters but it's also because you know
clubs you're so personal right and then
he's just out there you know in a club
is easy to control 400 yeah but now you
got to control
1800 but so no check spot no chicken
wings no Heckle it's it's a little more
uh we're happy to be there yeah it's a
it's Chris Rock said this once he goes
it's velvet seats oh he's got something
about velvet seats they behave better
it's true all right that's a bigger
ticket price yeah it's more expensive
they really have to want to be there as
opposed to clubs sometimes those clubs
have like a mailing list you know they
know who you are but they they're not as
invested I think in the clubs but I I'm
with you I love clubs too I did clubs
for so long I love
I mean I I you learn to love it I mean
right part of you know you're gonna slip
into theater like a dirty foot in a
sheet you're gonna love it you're gonna
slip right in
like a
toenailless hoof in the bed
just calling back
all right all right
what is that fat mats you say I gotta
check that out
I thought Cecil got [__] this is I'm
just saying I think you're gonna like
when you start doing them you're gonna
You're Gonna Love It I agree with Mark I
think you're really gonna I'm excited
I'm excited oh yeah I got about 13 14
days so far so I'm excited that is
exciting yeah it's a jump the big house
the theaters you're killing it you're
gonna like it
yeah you gotta sell a liquor have you
thought about that
no Amaretto oh miss Pats I do like
Amarillo and I'm ready to go because he
looking cute to me all right I turned
you around
have you been with the uh the Whitey
yeah we'll be a little white oh I'm a
good transition no you're not you won't
even feel me
I'm quite sure I want
you don't feel me because I don't have
to probably be on time
all right bring it on he's smashing the
[__] out of you wake up and you're gonna
be dead and you know once white people
die you leave them out too long you turn
into black people
to let the door is all
something to look forward to yeah so I'm
gonna look forward to Black well I'm
gonna suck those nail his toes all day
oh [__] okay all right
so you got some clubs coming up it looks
like when does this come out man
um these I'm in Kansas City
um well when did this come out
April what what
okay
that's a good room
uh 21st and 22nd of April classic great
I also have a podcast going on that week
oh make sure y'all get the tickets to
that hell yeah
April 28th and 20th in Tacoma Washington
good room yeah those are theaters yeah
that's it don't walk around too much in
the downtown area in Tacoma a little
messy a little messy
when I was there when I was there with
uh Gary veter we were in the hotel and
the power we're in the nice hotel in the
area but the power kept going out so
it's like we would just be in the room
I'd be like there's your power but the
power's out then we get in the elevator
for the for the building and it's broken
they're like oh be careful the elevator
it's broken what is be careful we're on
the 23rd floor what do you mean be
careful so we get in and it's stuck and
Gary's trying to get us out and some
guys are drunk they're like it's fine
it's fine Gary pushed the guy out of the
way wow to get us out and I was like and
then they got stuck so we got we got
[__] lucky yeah but uh it is a good
club though Tacoma yeah I like Tacoma a
lot of I wanted to mention about Pat
that uh her theater tour starts in
September okay get those tickets now and
it starts in Louisville on September 8th
and on the 9th in Indianapolis oh going
back to the home went on sale this week
this week it sure did hell yeah go to
misspackcomedy.com for all the dates and
and you give me get your tickets I love
it we can hang out now we're talking
it's so toenails yeah
just suck my toes tour that's pretty
good this girl done made it and uh Sammy
you got your dates up here yeah but I
got it they're adding more we got like
you know La San Diego Sacramento and uh
SF but we're adding a bunch of stuff we
got Columbus Cincinnati Indy Kalamazoo
Perrysburg York Pennsylvania Bethlehem
I'm all over Pennsylvania Wilmington
Delaware Baltimore Philly uh what's so
what why are you laughing at me
you just hear the word you're gonna have
to do too okay yeah because I'm a
totally get me on local TV and burn a
hole all right uh Hampton Beach Portland
Maine Connecticut Richmond Virginia
Greensboro Asheville Charlotte Knoxville
Memphis uh Birmingham so much more
coming you know Denver Santa Fe San
Antonio Houston let's go hell yeah
shamrock.com shows all right I'm coming
to uh a theater near you and you want me
to read this no and this is my website
ladies on fentanyl so this is all out of
whack
uh I'm coming to do it a theater tour
announcing it soon and I'm coming to
Australia this summer June so say hello
uh down under and uh
markdormancomedy.com get some Bodega cat
check out what was your podcast my
podcast is called to pat down make sure
y'all go and watch season three of the
Miss Pat show cause it's hours now and
if you you if you've never heard of the
Miss Pat show cause I've never done this
podcast and it might be a new audience
start at season one I'm gonna start
watching I'm pumped I'm pumped it's
really good it's really good I mean
nominated folks I'm gonna give it a plug
real quick uh as always I'm at Joey
Rose's Tuesday oh yeah guys come down
and see me at the bar there you go I
bartender for real I am yeah started
jota Rose's place on 174 Rivington
Street sing it sister
and uh yeah
you ain't [__]
y'all better start listening to him mad
[__]
you didn't hear that you better start
listening
you ain't [__] you're the only person
who listens to me
uh podcast
I barely got that out but yeah he was
eating it should have been a patent
stopping for us yeah all right I thought
you got Arnold Schwarzenegger the
groping oh that dude doesn't matter all
right look great episode so nice to have
you on the show thank you I really
appreciate it killed it and uh all you
guys Matt Peter Salamanca everybody Pat
rocker that baby ass this kid you beat
this kid up [__] yeah beat the dog too
you see that dog
great episode thanks for listening we
might be drunk keep drinking Sunday
[Music]
this woman doesn't look like I remember
her and I get down in the same way
we might
be true
[Music]